we we have the great judd apatow here
now Judd let's start this off do you
have an opinion on Brendan's shirt
because well it has a you know paint
like Jackson Pollock painting on it you
know I didn't go
I wasn't painting before this we know
I'm an artist yeah I'm an artist if you
were to be a bad artist is this is too
much pain okay you're a sloppy painter
but you know that's fashion see I I
don't understand fashions about two or
three years ago I said I look weird and
everything I can't decide with my
fashion is I'm not like Eurotrash guy
I'm not like preppy guy so I just
someone gave me a James purse polo shirt
I said I was gonna wear that I wear
James first polo shirt literally 95 yes
I've just decided I'm wearing right now
this is yeah I feel like this to move
for like like old people aren't in the
fashion it's like jeans
yeah salt oh he makes fun of me all time
he bought me these boots
he bought me for me for my birthday I
could give you some style for my 50th
yeah and I were James purse in jeans
I can't I can't figure it out and so
I've just given up completely you know I
remember I you know I met Wes Anderson
when he was really young first moved to
town
and then at some point he just started
dressing well it just showed up here and
and you know he was just a you know you
know a struggling filmmaker then he
decided okay this is what I look like
I'm gonna made a choice and he looks
amazing yeah it's like I'm like you know
Tom Wolfe guy or whatever and I just
never could figure out what the what's
the move we need a stylist as he did he
hired a bad idea really I was just I was
gonna say does he have a stylist because
I feel like guys that hire stylist so
stars go well this is what soon right
now you should be wearing this like no I
don't that's not as offensive it I have
no sense that I never did me neither you
know also I'm always in slightly bad
shape so would close never look right at
me
I've always found always it slightly bad
shape you know it's just and I think
every shirt look wrong cuz there's
nothing worse I'm like a little gut you
know that's enough there you gotta go if
I call it a faux pas you dare go fool
God work school or just go we would
bigger at least it's a statement yeah
good demo for V know it a little bit
yeah
it's the little good and so there was
this article about dad bods and my
friend sent it three think you should
read this article about dad bods it just
guys have got kind of a shitty body like
slightly shitty and I clicked on the
link and there was a photo and I swear
to god the photo was of me if you were
looking up as an Atlantic a I was like
the representation of the dad but just
content so I've been trying to lose
weight because I'm I'm taping a Netflix
special the end of July in Montreal nice
I'll be there so I'm gonna come see you
well that's just for lastly yeah so
everyone in Montreal should come see me
I'm going to be at the end of July ever
be the Wilbur I gotta get my plugs out
of the way just because yeah literally
no one wants that's all you mean by the
[ __ ] Adam I think it's it's at the 24th
omit the Wilbert Boston I'm a Ridgefield
Connecticut I think it's a 23rd I might
be off by a day but Ridgefield
Connecticut and then also in Providence
Rhode okay where we're about some rot
project is it the Columbus
it's Judd Apatow look at eyes we'll
figure it out yeah envision what's funny
about watching your stand-up is when I'm
such a fan of your movies but then I was
watching you stand up this is before I
knew you had done it before and I was
like he's [ __ ] gonna stand up to like
what the [ __ ] is going on what's funny
about you is it you know by the way yes
so go see Judd point is he's really
funny but but the point is even doing
stand-up longer than yeah in 1985 which
I didn't realize when he was 17 I said
the one he's 20 year break yeah make
big-time movies but I was thinking
during that time I was generally in your
office together he ready for the returns
well that like that's what cracks me up
about like you know you've kind of been
doing something that I think very so
many people try to do but you seem to
keep you always put out these great
movies and I think the biggest thing
about your movies is that they're you
know we want to turn 10 assume that you
answer these questions and talk about
it's a [ __ ] about sometimes but what I
like about your movies is that they're
not just hilarious they're also like
their real stories like where you follow
the character so your your discipline as
a storyteller is pretty pretty you know
well honed which is pretty amazing but
well we try to make good movies yeah I
think some people just want to make
movies they just want to make some money
get something greenlit yeah and so
they're looking for premises but
I'm always looking for like something
that someone is so passionate about like
the people making the movie will kill
for the movie like yeah we have a movie
coming out this Friday in New York and
le then it comes out on July 14th around
the country called the big sick so
Kumail Nanjiani um from Silicon Valley
wrote this movie with his wife Emily so
he comes in pictures me a couple ideas
and some of them are just ideas for
movies but then he says but and then I
had this experience with my wife when I
first met her where you know we weren't
getting along great because my parents
wanted me to have an arranged marriage
and I didn't talk talking and I didn't
know how to what to do la Castagna right
he's practice on him pay me when he's 18
and then I saw I was fighting with her
about that and then she gets sick one
day I go to a hospital and they say we
need to put her in a coma to try to
figure out what's wrong with her and
then I wound up in a hospital for a week
hanging out with her parents waiting for
her to hopefully get better and it's an
amazing story she's real and this is
real it's a crazy story the craziest
part of it is the doctor said to Kemal
are you the husband we need you to sign
this form to put her in the coma and he
said I'm not the husband and the doctor
said we need you to sign this form
because you're the husband right why and
he signed the form and they intubated
her and put her in a coma damn but I
think I guess he was saying she's going
to die if someone doesn't yeah yeah or
yes I'm so please lie on the form crazy
story that doctor so we said how do we
make this movie hysterical but real at
the same time yeah it took three or four
years of a zillion drafts and we got Ray
Romano and Holly Hunter to play his
wife's parents Zoe Kazan to play his
wife and the movie it might be the best
movie I've ever been a part of really
it's just it's just a Jemison and three
to four years yeah it we're 98 percent
on Rotten Tomatoes Wow and cheese and
then you get to the question how do you
get people to get off their asses and go
to the movie theater in this day and age
when you have so much at all Mountain
yeah but you know it's rare to go to a
movie theater and
watch a movie with people and to have it
kill like that experience like when you
see a great movie that's hysterical and
moves you and that's what this is so
hopefully people will go it's a great
test of if people who believe somehow
your language is so high I've never I've
never gone to I swear to god I'm not
saying I've never gone to one in your
movies where I that's quite what I mean
was first thing I told you is I when I
met you I was like you're able to
constantly write these movies and you
just put out these great movies over and
over again how weird is sitting in a
crowd the first because you I'm sure
that you go through tests and all that
but then where it's like a premiering
you're sitting in the crowd seeing the
fans reactions
well the scariest is the test you know
so when you finish a movie what you
usually do is if you watch it alone with
the editor and then you're you're
depressed for weeks I don't care what
movie it is like ah do you want to kill
yourself
it never is right and it always feels
unfixable when you first watch it then
you try to fix it and then you show
whatever 15 friends 30 friends get some
notes their notes are usually semi
helpful but usually completely different
than a real crowds notes because your
friends are too smart or I'm seeing too
many movies or whatever and then you go
to a mall somewhere and you get 300
strangers and that's the scary one and
you find out in five minutes really five
minutes if they are going to go on this
ride with you or not I remember the
first king of knocked up I don't know
why but they found all of Seth's friends
of a noxious and annoying the way we had
edited them it would started out with
Seth in bed and we had this whole thing
of he's sleeping and Jason Segel blows
pot into his nose while he's sleeping
and whatever the jokes are just a little
too weird or edgy and they hated like
Seagal and Jonah and Jay Baruchel and
Martin Starr and they're all friends too
right and their friends in real life
because they're often freaks and geeks a
lot of yeah but at the time people
didn't know them that well freaks and
geeks was in the hit those they had in
hidden movies and then we had to sit and
go which jokes make the crowd hate them
and then we figured it out it was like
three jokes that were too harsh or too
obnoxious and we plucked them and
suddenly they were the favorite part of
the
and that happens in these tests the
biggest test we ever had was was super
bad because we didn't know how well it
was working and the first time we showed
it it's a mall in Burbank it was like a
who concert the places the thing we
could load yeah we couldn't believe it
this movie the big sick
oddly tested higher than super rad
tested higher than bridesmaids what
people really love this movie so I hope
people go the Big Thicket New York and
LA Friday and then in two weeks around
the country how many people have these
these ideas for a movie and then they
like this is a jet project we want Judd
to do this because 40 year old virgin
was that Steve was they proud out great
because it didn't you know if his idea
for the movers he had an idea of this
four year old virgin how it go down and
he brought it to you or you just heard
it like how's that work well it used to
be really hard to get people a break to
be the lead of a movie it was just very
hard for something to say we're gonna
gamble on an unknown or generally
unknown person to be the lead of the
movie and my theory always has been that
people almost prefer to see someone they
don't know but they just like the
freshness of a new person them so I was
going to ask you because it feels like
the day of the movie star opening a
movie if you look at a lot of those
movies that are making it yeah it
they're making a fortune with basically
just good actors or unknowns or people
that are right for the part does the
story right yeah and all that so so
because you've got people like Johnny
Depp and all these people that are not
getting you a return on your investment
expense they were spending so much money
on these guys out they thought were is
is that still is that really the case
well it used to be that you know certain
people and there's there still are a few
that people going to see them in
anything so you knew there was like a a
bottom that was decent but you know any
Tom Cruise movie is going to make a
certain amount of money rightly no
matter what it is and that seems to be
happening less and less so there's still
those people but not many of them and I
think that people like to see Amy
Schumer in a movie they like to see
commitment Johnny in a movie and so with
Carell we were doing anchorman and he
was the weatherman of brick Tamland you
didn't come and - yeah and and he and he
was killing so hard Carell
yeah and Adam and Adam can those guys
say they knew him from second city a
they all knew how hilarious he loved
these but he was murdering where even
the whole cast of anchorman was like
what is happening on this sack and so I
just said to him one day he got any
ideas where you're the star of the movie
and he came to me the next day he's like
you know I did a sketch at Second City
about 40 year old virgin you know and
it's him at a poker game and everyone's
telling sex stories and his make no
sense because clearly he hasn't had sex
and then he started doing it to me and I
read what he did he's like you know like
when you put your hand on a a woman's
panties and is all the baby powder and
you know how like a breast feels like a
bag of sand and I just made me laugh and
I instantly knew exactly what it should
be because it was a way to do it where
it's real you feel for the person's not
making fun with her is amazing about the
dozen similes in that movie is your wife
which is the drunk chick driving
tomorrow yeah yeah Rose oh yeah oh how
about it's hard on in the beginning of
the movie where you're just like god
damn it's so real it's so real just walk
around this giant hard-on you know
what's so funny about comedy you know
you ever sit home and you're writing a
joke yeah and you get so excited with
your joke that you literally stand up
and run around like you figure out like
no one's done business yeah how could no
one do the joking for me I'm soon I know
if I was over in the office and I
thought I've never seen someone try to
piss with a boner on screen I've never
seen it and I ran around the house like
I cured cancer I was so happy every day
is it so memorable no it was so good and
the day we shot it I was so happy then
you know we did some version like the
team hits him in the face
yeah at some point and then we did weird
outtakes where we really let him pee in
his own face because he couldn't push it
down far enough that's so stupid but it
really is those moments that make you
believe in the Lord yes the Lord just
gave me this pee with a boner joke it's
so true man but you seem to keep
conflict this is kind of interesting too
because I'm Brendan who was a football
player profiler
then has always fantasized about being a
comedian never told anybody and with
Dalton we started doing this podcast yes
I noticed that he was really good at
telling stories I was like this guy's
funny he had me and Rogan howling one
time of the story so I was like let's do
a podcast long story short it starts
becoming this big thing and he kind of
like we're closed right so he didn't
really want to admit to me that he
wanted to stand up
oh yeah it's scary to admit it before
you do it yes I did admit it for years
when I was a kid I'd I'd hug there's
nothing lamer than saying you want to be
a stand-up before hear us - yeah I'd
like to be a kid right so he looks at me
and he goes um I'm thinking about
telling stories you know I mean just
getting out this town stories about
fighting and you know what my life my
life and I was like mm hmm interesting
I'll go you wanted to stand up because I
mean I wouldn't say stand up and I was
like hmm but I gave my back man like he
wants to do stand-up long story short he
shows up with sick in the head your book
Oh
and he's reading all about Judd Apatow
and all about comedy and yeah it was
helpful Kapil yeah this is weird yet
because yeah and but when we were
backstage at the comic store together
I've never met you before I saw you back
there I'm like well you know comic so
you say hi to each other back then I'm
like man I don't be that weirdo I
respect you know I respect you and so I
was like eh man read your book sick in
the head it helped me out tremendously
like oh cool man we start talking about
that but this is what's weird is that
sick in the head people ask me all the
time about a how'd you get started what
helped you and I tell them obviously at
you know Brian counts with a huge help
and Rogen and deleting the guys Bert but
there's not a lot of content out there
and kind of I don't know give you kind
of a pathway or or how other comics
they're thinking or where they had in
their career and then when I got too
sick in the head it's interesting
because you start it when you're a kid
yeah so you're asking questions for you
know guy you know I've always been in
the comment I know comedy but you're
this young kid who has all these
aspirations and goals and you're asking
questions where someone who doesn't have
their black belt in comedy I would have
same thing at 30 yeah you read the book
in the Steve Martin which I read is you
know born standing up and I freakin that
book was amazing but I Fermi was tough
to relate to Steve Martin but when I'm
reading your
it's going through all these guys like
their confidence Jerry Seinfeld had and
you know he show up as a kid and he's
telling them he's booking it himself Lee
shows up like with that this is a kid
and everyone's pretty cool they still
let him do it yeah but so that book
really helped me to kind of find my way
a little bit in this weird world and
trust me I'm still trying to find it you
know how it goes and then you're on the
show today and tonight I shoot for
Comedy Central
oh wow weird yeah well this is what
happening for you this is not happening
oxo yeah excellent yeah re yeah yeah
that's right ik yeah well it's your kind
of interesting though because like the
way saying this is like it you know I
have talked people who knew you back
then and they all were like he's going
to run this town but you don't come
across that way so when you talk when
you meet people that are like that
typically they're they're just very
type-a they're very kind of like you
know you know what I mean there's a
profile to fit that sort of the guy the
director the producer and there's no
time and when I see you attract me up is
that knowing very accessible and you're
you know you're basically like the
characters you [ __ ] write about let's
be honest yes although although those
characters aren't disciplined those
characters are getting high all the time
you're just not that guy there's no way
you could be as successful as you are
and be that like B well thank God I
didn't know that works for me ever and
never did he never did I just would get
tired I remember I had a girlfriend many
many moons ago and we smoked pot and I
just get tired and I just falsely I just
fall tonight as I'm working at work yeah
and the girl to her it's like acid it's
like she's on meth she's all adrenaline
yeah and I wake up in the morning and
she's gone and I call her and she had
taken a bus home at 5:30 it was all
hopped up on marijuana a bus that's me
doing doing I shut down a [ __ ] bus I
shut down me too I can't if I smoke weed
I'm a complete zombie and I stay high
for like five hours I said the Rogen I
smoked some of his magic weed I was a
problem it's it's been five hours I got
a day I got it I can't even drive I'm
eating chicken yeah yeah but what to
Singh is the switchy the guys you
interviewed in the sick in the head
is most of them were super disciplined I
mean there's there's a few but in
general you everyone that booked like
Seinfeld is a straight killer lucky
revalue he's waking up he's riding for
two hours every morning still writing
baby - I play myself so you remember
Lucien hold you might yes yeah yeah so
solution was kind of first got to give
me my you know spots in New York you
know Baylor - big big supporter of say
yes yes and he had something called
scleroderma so he was dying but he was
very elegant man you know didn't rush
things and will run a good stuff miss
make sure you respect the light and
stuff like that and he was talking about
sign thought he knew Jerry really well
and when Jerry had his first appearance
on Carson it was going to be five
minutes yeah and apparently Jerry
trained for that five minutes like a
professional athlete like he would get
up and run he would run and as he was he
with jog and he would think about his
set over and over again then he had a
set time the way he would practice it
and it was literally military so by the
time he got he knew what that five
minutes was really he crushed it and you
know when I did it Tonight Show I
finally did stand-up on The Tonight Show
Jimmy Fallon asked me to do it but I
always thought and this was about a year
and a half ago I always thought that he
asked me because he thought it would be
amusing even if I bombed yet I was a
little more of a circus act yeah because
though it isn't that I - even asked me
what my jokes were he was just like just
here's a five minute here you go
make it vibe and hit your marks exactly
nobody it was so it was a professionally
presented set but anyway I worked really
hard to do set and you know for me as a
as a kid especially growing up in the
late 70s and early 80s The Tonight Show
was a giant as a comedian that really
was your dream to get on The Tonight
Show and so I was on the show and Adam
Sandler was the other guest
you know Mike Mike my old friend
roommate at Vail Ruben yeah and a few
days before it louis c.k I know a little
bit but not especially well but it was a
great guy he he wrote me an email
telling me how to do the Tonight Show oh
my god and it was long it was one of the
nicest things anyone's ever done
yeah it was just here's what you got it
was just a list of different things you
wouldn't think Wow such as is the
weather baby laugh the most would you
walk out on stage there will be music
playing do not dance to it that music is
not for you to dot be on advice do not
pop your head but it's Johnny so what
according to pop your head you're right
hey I'm great I'm just hanging out
enjoying the music yeah you also said
you know one of the scariest things ever
is standing behind the curtain while the
music is playing knowing you're about to
be announced and then suddenly you're
gonna be shot out of a rocket because
it's as scary as anything yeah what you
should do in that moment is you wait for
your name to be announced is just think
of your first joke only your first joke
and think about why you wrote it and
think about why it made you laugh and
that will going to set your path for
your sincerity and yeah and then what
was sweaty as I read this and I thought
is so nice that he did that it really
blew me away ten two hours later a
second one came in with just as long
really even more to my masterpiece
tomorrow
well bye much man you know overthink it
was like a magazine article and I swear
to God I took every piece of advice I
very seriously I read it thought about
it did it and it was out wow cuz I one
of the things as fascinating as watching
you you know here you are the pretty
damn successful but you always have your
notepad out early just stand up you're
writing I like the other day I came
backstage we were on the same venue and
judge writing like I saw you writing
jokes and [ __ ] I was like guys got his
notebook out like working [ __ ] out well
I don't really know another way to do it
but what makes me laugh is when I used
to do stand-up so I did it for the time
I was 17 I was 24 and I was a regular
the improv and I got on not Letterman in
the sideshow but basically everything
else the young age video and comedians
special and evening and improv and all
those shows Dennis Miller show was the
show I got on to do stand-up a lot but
his talk show but I don't think I wrote
anything down back then yeah I little
notes little bullet points at all here
yeah I don't know what I was doing I
remember Larry Miller who was one of the
best comics old-timer saying judge it's
like a job and if you sit down at a desk
and you write for a few hours a day like
it's a job you'll instantly be better
than everybody yeah because he said
because nobody does it everyone just
goes to the mall it's hard to do nobody
sits and treats it like a job and but I
didn't like I go through all my old
notes and there's nothing and now I have
thousands of pages of jokes The Tonight
Show why it's because it's not as big as
it used to be right because there's so
much content out there yeah it was like
you're not like it's not it used like
back in the day like Carson or few on
Leno especially Letterman Letterman at
the time was I did Letterman in 99 and
I've never been it was part of this new
committee with me Dane Cook it was part
of this new comedian thing and I've
never been I never I don't really never
suffer from nerves doing stand-up but
I've never been more nervous because it
was the [ __ ] stage that at Letterman
well it was where the Beatles play
actually and where Elvis plays if you're
talking about the Beatles while out I
now behave it couldn't help it I was
like solve it I know you know I know and
then I see letter them sitting down
behind a curtain he's I saw his mug his
coffee mug maybe I panic I don't know
why because it was Letterman and also he
didn't want to Ebisu
no this is by the way we saw us is the
worst ready so check this out so [ __ ]
this is the worst I wake up that morning
and I've been nervous all week and again
I don't get nervous
I wear the morning and I go mmm my lip I
got a little oh is that a blister I'm oh
I have herpes sore middle I met Burpee
says oh come on now it was like guys and
I was like oh I've her Peas on national
TV dress her pieces oh I had a stretcher
but that's great as the makeup woman's
trying to cover my stress her pee in the
mirror how much she goes it's hard for
me to cover I go okay I'll go out there
with a shrimp on my [ __ ] with a baby
one of those little I was like this is
awesome I can't wait
and so I go out there and I had to wear
a suit I remember I was told if you
don't wear a suit
you'll meet resistance David Letterman
thinks you should wear a suit you know
that he likes his comedians to be
you know I mean while I watch Mitch
Hedberg as I go [ __ ] yourself but he was
Mitch Hedberg right but I just never
forgot as I was doing my song and dance
nervous I kind of calm down it was fine
after that because I'm the audience the
audience that ought to break is agree
they laughs I mean they're like and you
guys said Paul Shay I love like thought
about the Beatles I thought about to be
a semester but like when we did Cobb's
and Sam Sisko right before I went on the
guy because that we always said to show
I do 10 15 minutes of comedy the
stand-up stood show my god the guy goes
I play before I go out you know I'm
nervous that seasons that oh yes right
for a guy he got his brother Robin
Williams here all the time
great I went Thanks all right yeah cool
man yeah ah yeah as I turned in the
middle of my set I I swear to God
Letterman was doing something in his
desk she was in pizza dude no he was
like rummaging around in the I swear to
god I'm gonna do well I get late I
invite you over to the table no Paul
Schrader said to me is that it Schaefer
said to me Bulger is a writer of taxi
driver and the comfort of strangers
research he as well he is well they bug
you but he came up to me and he goes at
the end of it because you killed and I
was like all right it's like I don't
know but there are certain signs ready
for you to invite right that's like how
you know you're doing well I had a
message back in the day that was I was
worried but jobs are something Willie
let you sit yes to him yeah and I hate
everything I do anyway so okay so I I
was way ahead of anybody if it was it
was it was bad I'm Way ahead I did
Letterman once it just as a guest and he
was so nice to me when I came out that
he completely ruined me really I just
assumed it would take a little work to
melt him and then he was so warm
instantly and I hadn't prepared myself
mentally to be like in that vibe yeah I
thought I'd have to really work with it
after you'd become it was I think four
knocked up I always remember that he was
showing the clip and it was a clip of
Jason Segel maybe I forgot what the
scene was but I think was Jason Segel
hitting on my wife Leslie Mann in the
bar but in
middle to Clippy just turned to me and
goes that guy that guy how can flood it
you know that yeah to what um to what
degree is is uh this is forty like so
much like your life cuz you might be
that was in jail I did about the
calendar that's my like I watch on my
crying yes to this movie brother he I
think you snooping in on you [ __ ] I
was [ __ ] crazy I like it's fighting my
wife I had to make this all the time
because the second you put Paul Rudd
into it ninety percent is different just
in the way you talk in the way you fight
and in what you know the behavior in the
houses so it certainly was partially
stuff that you know we've been through
and a lot it probably even more stuff we
had observed from all of our friends in
that age group and some people gave us a
hard time about it but what I thought
was interesting was just the idea of you
know having a life having financial
problems and trying desperately to not
admit there happening yeah as your world
crumbles and also about how a man
doesn't want to admit he's having
trouble and he's lying and and then all
the stress that creates another distance
it creates and I'm really happy that it
that movie seems to be holding up really
well I it's more than most of the movies
when people talk about it but also like
I can't think of a moving you know it's
not a huge issue especially in society
right now but it's a wealthy Brentwood
family you know and everyone thinks
everything's all done [ __ ] yeah I'll
know it's not all out it will be annoyed
but that they're like why are they
complaining they have a nice car now is
alarms man yeah it is a liberal knows
Paul you know you I mean come on how
many people do we know that are you
would think our house their names I mean
if they are having major financial
problems they're letting people they
don't have [ __ ] month what about
putting your kids in the movies it's
funny because my kids are older down my
daughters are 19 and 14 and lately I
think part of it is I don't want to meet
other people's kids like I don't have to
sit on a set with someone else's yes and
their parents but I also always found my
kids to be hilarious they just always
made me laugh their relationship with
each other it makes
laughs just you know what they fight us
about makes me laugh and in a way I
think it's a result of being a hoarder
because I thought if they're in the
movie I'm gonna have so much footage of
them and I'll be able to own this moment
in time and now that it has been 10
years since knocked up I'm so glad it
exists because they're not like that
anymore
right and it was surprising to me
because I follow you on Instagram and
obviously you know knocked up in 40 old
versions on TV long time so you see your
kids in that light you know the same
thing we're like Stevo came in here I
see Stevo from MTV's jacket yeah we come
they're like damn he's just so when you
post a picture I do some premiere some
with your kids I like came out who the
[ __ ] god yeah can't stop it you try to
stop it here man DK and my son is five
and I keep I swear to god I want to
stunt his growth I'm just like he's so
damn cute when my bike kid was always
trying to walk early and mod my oldest
walked really early ten months and so
when I was tried to walk early we didn't
want it to so I would knock her down
would you want them to be actors well
they do act and I'm happy for anyone to
be able to avoid hard work in life not
that acting isn't easy I mean know that
it is in the heart it is very hard it's
emotionally very hard and it's a scary
profession because you never know if
you're ever going to work again but
there's still so much fun to it if you
could get to work and express yourself
so my daughter iris is on our showed
love with this show love on Netflix and
she plays a spoiled child star on a bad
show about witches and the lead guy is
the set teacher to her and she's
hysterical and then my other daughter
who's a 19 mod was in this great movie
called other people with Molly Shannon
last year and she hollered oh mine
doesn't work enough I love her oh she's
brilliant in the UM in the movie she won
the Independent Spirit Award for Best
Actress and and so they're both getting
into it but I would tell them you got to
write because you don't want to sit
around hoping someone thinks you're a
good actress you want to just be able to
make your project right you want to be
like Lena Dunham you want someone to be
someone who you just sit down and say
here's what to do next I'm going to
write it
do it have you have you done a movie
that wasn't really successful I've done
movies that didn't make a lot of money
uh I don't really have a movie where I
think oh god that's so bad I feel like
the worst of them would still be the
best movie you'd ever watch on a plane I
think yeah but with Noel I wonder with a
guy like you like you at now you're not
even 50 yet and you've done is you know
you've been as successful as it gets
right let's be honest so now what are
what you ever find yourself kind of
being like I don't know what else to do
or well that's partially why I like
doing stand-up yeah because you know if
you say okay the bar is can I be as good
in a special as Maria Bamford or
Hannibal or Louie or Mulaney the bar is
so high yeah that it's it's so fun to
try to see if you can get there and to
me that's always what I've been
interested in movies and television just
know can I do my best work and I get the
most out of me something original right
so that's why it's so fun to go to the
Wilbur and bus and I'll be at the
Wilbur's little Rhode Island and
Providence and Ridgefield Connecticut
you you've been around company forever
since you're a kid and people say so
it's our boy Rogan we'll say this is the
Golden Age of comedy right now yeah it's
better than it's ever been you agree
with that I think so he's really I I
mean I wasn't expecting that I mean you
could look at it like no one is as good
as Richard Pryor so it's not no one's as
good as Steve Martin so it's not but I
think that we always look through it
look at it through the prism of that
time and when you're young what had an
impression on you but if you're a young
kid and you don't know anything about
comedy and you see oh hello with Kroll
and Mulaney on Netflix
that's your Steve Martin yeah or Maria
Bamford what she's doing I'm credible I
mean yeah she makes me laugh I mean
there i want i favorite she in many ways
like for me having been in this business
as long Maria Bamford is so good at
shocking like for me I think she's if
you want to talk about original I think
she might be the most original comic
male female yeah I ever me and gets
better and better
and I on an episode of her show playing
myself I have a sewed six for those out
there of lady dynamite and I don't
really act but she said can you do this
part where you offer me a job in a movie
and I'm so afraid of success I say no
and she comes to my office and we
improvise and it's so fun and in the
second season she put me in an episode
and I said okay third season I want an
arc I want I need you to me is the only
acting I could do is a version of myself
who's just an [ __ ] like my [ __ ]
but you're not okay I would tell him do
this one especially when I was writing a
lot I I found like I don't relate to a
lot of comics like like I read the Steve
Martin book it kind of broke my heart
kinda went down a dark road or I read a
bunch of other but you know comedy kind
of biography stuff like that and but
yours was one of the especially when
it's you and Adam Salem when he first
moved to LA and it just hear me out it
kind of broke my heart because you
talked about how you realized when you
saw Jim Carrey and they saw Adam Sandler
just doing prank calls that you know you
couldn't compete with those guys kind of
staged so that's when he started writing
yeah but to me that made me sacks I'm
like what here's a brilliant mind and
comedies really uh not how you look or
anything like that and you're comparing
yourself to Adam Sandler and Jim Carrey
who you're talking about two freaks
that's like any basketball played like
I'm not like LeBron so I'm not gonna try
this out well it's a weird piece of bad
luck to be starting as a comedian at a
very young you know what screw Jeff well
it's funny cuz I think Adam gets annoyed
when I say this because he was my
biggest fan as a comedian he was always
just such a massive supporter and when I
did Carnegie Hall last year I did my set
and then after it's Adam came out into
the surprise hour after me then we sang
a song together it was magical really
was with that but it is like trying to
be a songwriter and your roommates John
Lennon that's what it felt like and and
then you think what am i doing I don't
think of my songs or as good as his
songs especially because what Adam was
doing was so strange and so
wonderful when he was young was really
weird fact hanging-style a it was before
he wasn't even doing the guitar he was
doing you know Elvis lives in my
refrigerator very very like surreal
comedy and then Jim Carrey I just quit
doing impressions and he would go
onstage and improvise the whole act and
half the time he would kill half the
time he would bomb but like really Bob
yeah like like people leaving masks and
within the same set he'd lose him get
him back lose him and it was so creative
and I felt at a time watching Jam oh
this is the biggest star in the world
and no one here knows it yeah you could
just feel it bubbling up and it was very
intimidating to me because as a fan I
knew oh I'm not like these guys now as
someone who's 49 years old I have a lot
of stories and I have a point of view
and it's and it's different right but as
a kid I felt like that screwed like I
was reading I'm like that kind of screws
I can relate to that in the sports world
because my best friend was this guy Joe
Kaufman Stein and he was a 1% of the
premier premier athlete he was shredded
662 and 70 pounds fast me everything I'm
like well that that's a professional I
don't know what I'm gonna do so he gave
me this chip on my shoulder I'm like I
got to work harder cuz I'm not like him
but when I was reading your your book I
was a guy he got screwed kind of being
best friends Adam Sandler have him as a
roommate and that's the level that more
more he got lucky because what he did is
went on to MIT write amazing movies and
become like this I don't I'm not upset
about the fact that I didn't do stand-up
all those years I got burnt out on it
too I love you so much I watched na I
watched so many comedians and I knew
everyone's act inside and out I was just
such a fan that I got a little burnt out
on it so I never think of myself ah man
we've been great to be a comedian in my
30s or whatever because it's so fun now
and it's fun to do it where I need to
pay my rent you know like there's a
pressure when you first start out to eat
yeah and so if I would go get a gig in
Rancho Cucamonga for 75 bucks
I needed that 75 bucks yes you know I
had my rent was $425 a month
I worked for yeah it was hard to get
when I was young and I are plenty of
comics still at 50 and 55 that it did
you know they had had their moment but
now they're back to trying to fill small
rooms and not making a lot of money and
they're great and they've been doing it
for as long as anybody likes to see CK
or anything else so stand-up is a tough
tough road when you're still flying
coach and still trying to rent that car
on a deal and still staying at Best
Western in a blizzard and a lot of
ageism I can just feel it I've talked to
guys like legendary guys who told me
about that like it's hard to get booked
in these clubs now yeah okay because
they're older just looking or they're
just not on the show the media they're
not on while I was talking to I just got
back from Australia I'm student Tommy
out there and I was like the promoter
and he was saying to that ageism stuff
he goes I don't book older guys anymore
older acts or if it's older me just
musicians because they don't have a
following on social media and if they
don't then I have to pay to market them
and sell tickets because I can split a
young kid who's really good on social
media has a subscription you know on
YouTube and it's gonna I don't have to
do anything he sells it himself yeah I
so why waste the dollars on it I used to
not be on anything and then he showed up
at a book store to promote my first book
which is called I found this funny it's
like a collection of like just short
stories and sketches and things that I
thought were funny just right things I
collected and I show it a book so with
my daughter there's 12 people there yeah
in this enormous bookstore well people
did and I said I got it I gotta find a
way to connect with people because
whatever you do things sometimes no one
shows up I did a Q&A with Cameron Crowe
I thought it would be packed for one of
my movies it was no one there and I want
and I came across a letter to make you
feel like nothing makes you feel like
more like a loser do what you got to do
is sliding you know and so yeah right
and you just always just bad promotion I
can't assume I never assume anyone's
gonna show up to anything I always get
on yeah I mean yep if they go do a Q&A
at the movie theatre after your movie
III hit it because I always show up my
big is over there my biggest thing
every time the worst one was I think it
was for this is 40 maybe this is the
worst one we had the screening it like
the Motion Picture Academy it was a big
theater like a 600 seat theater yeah and
there was like 40 people that we have to
do Q&A with the flag god it's so bad I
don't got to go it on Twitter and yeah
because you're competing with you know
everything and if you don't have people
that are actually you know because
everybody finds an excuse to do anything
else and you're getting them to get in
their car pay a babysitter and all that
stuff and drive to see you but also how
like it's never been easier to sell
tickets though you look at that it's
never been easier you are your own
publicist it's in your hand if you
cannot put together 144 characters on
why people to see you you shouldn't
[ __ ] me doing stand-up yeah
[ __ ] yeah tweet it's what's
interesting though is that if you didn't
grow up with that at all in your brain
the idea that you can do that is
something I've had to wrestle with you
know I'm a realist tonight you know I'm
all notice I mean this is a you yeah
they say yes you know some people have a
I don't know man it's also you're also
asking people of my generation at least
to self-promote which I've been told my
whole life my whole life has been that's
impolite it's a shitty it's Gross's it's
not what it's not what a man should do I
mean and all that stuff that you're kind
of like come see me I know let those
other people do that [ __ ] I want to do
with the work I get so nervous to
selling tickets because it's you know
with the movie it's terrifying because
you can't imagine you work out for years
and then sometimes they can tell you the
day before it opens what it will make
how it's like they can figure it out
just from pre-sales like they can
extrapolate and know and this is your
baby boy here's a big second opens
Friday you just go it's years of work I
know it's great are people gonna show up
I won't know you know till the day
before that's me that need a and but
with tickets I always laugh at Pete
Holmes because sometimes we go and do
concerts together and I always go like
Pete you're just such a terrible draw
you're so terrible and we'll be on
social media and like welcome I think
we're in a bad market is it
is it us like is it me like what is it
and then it always like sell out like
two days before like why is it always
like the second before we get there it
sells out that's how people I think on
social media are as well my dad ate the
procrastinate and I'll get it last it
depends like we added a second show at
the Wilbur and I'm you know I'm doing
these shows just to practice so I don't
really they're not really gigs for any
reason I need to run the Netflix special
and I want to do a good job and have fun
and so we added a second show for
charity for like the Boston like arts
for after-school arts right for kids so
that they could you know because that's
the first thing they ways cut is the
banners or plays or or something and so
then they put the new show on Salem like
okay we got a month we got a month and
I'm instantly terrified the whole month
more than a movie even really I know
that's why I'm glad I'm out of the real
games Arsenal because it's you exactly
like they're coming to see you and oh
yeah not like a movie like you know this
is we doing I like you right Phoenix
Arizona we do not like you sold a
seventy oh my god or do we cancelled
only one show me and Pete we cancelled
what show it was Irvine and everybody
was like oh baby was Anaheim yeah and it
looks like oh no because it's just
there's Disneyland there whatever like
that's the worst market yeah for
stand-up although it's still not enough
I'll tell you that and there's always an
excuse it's make you feel better right
exactly yeah yeah the games i well know
did like there's the car MacGregor Floyd
Mayweather fights on August 22nd Sal DC
I was on I was on you on speakerphone
we're in our agents office and you're
like I'm gonna do DC and I looked at
just like that's the night of Floyd
Mayweather McGregor it tell Brian he's
usually yeah there's gonna be one person
there to see him online
know what's going to happen at that
fight because I wouldn't have thought
about what's your prediction of how that
goes down
ah man and what are the rules no rights
which standard boxing rules 10 ounce
gloves 12 rounds yeah you know standard
boxing yeah standard boxing so it's good
it's gonna you know for con
it's going to be e he hits pressure on
him just because he represents the mixed
martial arts world and then obviously
Boyd meddler won the best of all time
and I argue this all time with people
it's going to take oh there's going to
be a feeling out period which is voids
ever seen Connor style Connors ever seen
Floyd Stiles give me this weird awkward
awkwardness for like the first few
rounds which I think Connor can win some
of those rounds then once Floyd kind of
figures out his timing distance the
awkwardness what
Connors game playing is so start to take
over and employ a win in a decision but
it's going to be a little bit of feeling
out there is their eyes can be the
biggest side of our lifetime and and
will it be a good fight can be
entertaining
yeah it's give me a better fight than
people think that's exciting I mean I
remember when I was a kid you know it
was like you know Ollie Holmes yeah you
know I remember the you know they would
have those things on like what was it
like what was it called like the closed
circuit would be people watch them in
bars and they were like paper via
closed-circuit TV closed-circuit Jimmy
and I cuz I remember very clearly as a
kid to Leon Spinks fight yes sure and
windows he alley remember yeah and it
was like what here's a kid you know I'm
ready to see if I remember hearing Leon
Spinks beat Muhammad Ali what is that
great documentary about Holmes beating
Ali yeah you know you know Holmes with
his sparring partner yeah four year
amazing again I don't break your heart
that documentary art if you watch it
because I lesion been fighting suffered
brain trauma well when you watch what is
that when we were Kings it's an amazing
Bangor entry and you watch Ollie
sparring with this dude these long arms
and he's just pop pop pop pop up and
you're like you can't help say whoever
that sparring partner is is really good
and then the headgear comes out
well that's Larry Holmes well that's
nothing new like anti Joshua's training
partners of Klitschko like this is how
it goes but quietly wasn't Larry Holmes
one of the best of all time he was so
boring
Azzam and not a drunk yeah but he killed
everybody and no one talks about
you have the personality of our craziest
job in the world he was all that in his
prime better than Ali in his prime 100%
yeah but he not funny it was a story to
be told that yeah he didn't have the
personality to back tired welcome he's
got money people only talk about mohali
when there's up there's better fighters
out there man
this is what no one ever talks about is
that when you're funny it changes
everything like I kept saying during the
election but I thought Trump was gonna
win yeah because he was funny yeah I
don't think he has a good sense of humor
about other people he's it you know he
is like an MC yeah and I thought Reagan
was a funny guy yes Clinton was funny
yeah Al Gore was not funny I thought was
funny Obama may be the funniest of all
time yeah I think so funny that he had
to hide how funny yeah yeah because I
remember watching him do a town hall I
was running for president he's taking
questions and he's just got kind of dark
and edgy with someone asking a question
like too funny and I thought oh you
can't be that funny you can't also be
he's not looking at giving people a hard
time and and right I mean I wrote jokes
for the Correspondents Dinner
oh I'm the year that he made fun of
Trump and I couldn't believe how
hysterical he was delivery his timing
his ability to wait like those pauses
we've never stumbled on a word oh I mean
he never used the don't everything I
wasn't my buddy my buddy John Durant was
talking about he knew Trump was gonna
win when Trump they were talking about
they said well you know Mitt Romney's
rich very rich and Trump goes he's not
rich I'm rich you know he's got a
hundred eighty million dollars I'm rich
like he embraced it liked it because
they were tell well tis a liability when
you run for president and you think and
their civic with the follow-up question
was Mitt Romney had trouble getting
votes because he was so wealthy do you
think you're going to have the same and
he wouldn't even he was so smart that I
go what well think he's not wealthy I'm
well dinner to next question like yeah
he just anybody embraced it he but you
know some people can get away with it
you know jay-z and Beyonce
can you say I slay
and I'm rich and I got vanilla Tigers
yeah bill uh yeah and it's good and then
like if I did that you should make shut
the [ __ ] all [ __ ] games you have to
have like testosterone behind it like
you got to kind of be like like there's
got to be a [ __ ] you to a no shame well
you must have a heart like you fall
Kevin Hart on Instagram right there on
Twitter I mean it like hits hashtag rock
star comedy [ __ ] and it's like him from
a private jet him and of Lamborghini
unlike he's always been if anyone ever
posted that like if a white guy was
doing that he'd be so screwed well you'd
have no fan he's so funny because Kevin
was like on the phone we're doing this
movie and he's talking he goes yeah so
just put the UM well you can put the TV
in there then I guess like yeah I don't
know how you're gonna Center it me and
go anyway sorry I'm having mansion
problems he's always been that guy like
I love I love his Instagram but you look
at how thing about the stuff today Tim
and his wife in a brand new like Bentley
Royals Royce a gold Rolex hanging out
he's like rich problem I'm like I can
you imagine if frickin bill burr did
that or you know it's interesting
because I think you know some of it is a
culture I had a joke about this once was
like you know like I can't brag about
money like I can't like oh yeah we we we
flew in a private jet but it was a
special time and I wouldn't do it again
is that any advice one time that's it
yeah you don't come across it but you
aren't Judd Apatow at the end of the day
you can fly privately so well I know you
mean I I'm doing a little awkward for
you I think if you started from nothing
you have that I made it you can make it
two things yes yes but Trump didn't
start from nothing he started was a we
were only puppets Trump's got that sort
of rough New York construction worker
thing like they always said he could
talk to construction workers could hurt
Trump is not what you'd consider like
he's not like an erudite intellectual
Trump is a his hands are dirty like you
can feel it he's a big kind of brash guy
hey dude yeah he's just like oh [ __ ] is
how I play golf more than everybody else
he doesn't even exercise though he said
that a size makes you tired oh yeah he
has a theory which I love that he's
created his own nutritional side goodies
he says that you only have so much
energy
de and he doesn't want to waste it uh no
because your body's a battery you have a
light battery and if you and so the
ultimate bro science yes I know he has
to my cousin has all those things he
talked about one is he says he's got
good stuff so his the blood his blood
which is Germanic he goes my just kind
of pretty it makes me a nothing he's
like I got good stuff my genetics are
very strong and then he looks at his
body as a battery so so you like only
has nobody beat yet I always say this
area so many hands so his friend if you
had literally took that too hard
that'll be fine kid and he took that the
heart was like you're right I only have
so many beats on network to know his
friends a triathlete and he's like
you're gonna die early you might be
hawaii's right he's so out of shape and
getting worse and just sitting there
even though they look because I was
really surprised with people like you
know George Bush and Obama have the time
to put in a real workout every day bomb
at a basketball court put in the White
House have court I I mean I certainly I
hate to say I relate to Trump because
I'm probably closer to Trump's and Obama
where I create my momentum
seiyya I say what I met Trump by the
impart they opened an improv in Atlantic
City and at the time Trump was at war
with Merv Griffin it's I remember very
well good I fight know so what exam Irv
told me this store oh great so I shot
something with Merck and Merv so so Merv
said they were talking about whether
he's as wealthy as Donald Trump so Merv
said well I'm a lot more wealthy than
Donald Trump because when they talk
about Donald Trump's wealth what they
always forget to say is they always
forget to mention one word debt so
Donald right yeah Merv Griffin yeah had
money and no debt okay
and so murder of the guy like that
that's tough like it's Merv but he'll
he'll kill the great bird by the way
wrote the theme song to jeopardy yeah
we're shooting that actress with cursey
Ali and he was he was a guest star and
he would he would do things like he'd
just start playing the piano and I had I
had this this watch my dad gave me it
was kind of a cool watch and I and he
goes it's a nice watch and me joking
around I go yet from Switzerland don't
touch it though yeah and he goes oh
don't is it
like a yeah it's expensive and he goes
oh I have this watch it's a it's a
vintage Rolex those are diamonds that
are tumbling around it as long as you
can touch it he said he is a great but
so with Donald Trump so he had a great
sense of humor and so Dom Trump said to
him he wrote him a letter a really nasty
letter essentially saying hey you can't
do this you know because I'm wealthy and
part of my brand requires that people
know that I'm wealthy and you can't you
can't make me look bad in the media and
basically this whole nasty thing and so
Merv wrote him back something kind of
quippy like joking right joking around
saying Oh take it easy whatever you know
don't be a baby and then I think he did
another interview where Murray iterated
that you know he's got that and that's
what will now check this out so then so
then Donald writes him back a really
nasty letter like with all kinds of
nasty um sort of profanity so so Merv
Gretl president bird Griffin oh I'm
sorry Merv Griffin said this in the
interview he said look if he keeps up
because because he started bad-mouthing
Merv on the interviews so Merv said look
if he keeps bad-mouthing me I'm going to
have to buy his buildings which won't be
difficult he doesn't really own them and
I'm gonna have to take the T off the
name of his rope so it says wrong and I
could do that so Donald Donald writes
back this really nasty letter now now
it's a really nice letter after he's old
school to write letters yes they're
writing left this is not can drive it
this is all private this is a Merv Tommy
so so he writes so he says you better be
careful but Merv I gets in the interview
said you better be careful I'll take the
T off your name I'll buy your billing
tape the onion so Donald writes him this
insanely letter with full of profanity
Merv Griffin took the letter and put a
little note on the top of the letter
sent it back to Donald Trump and it said
this Donald I think somebody's stealing
your stationery and writing me terrible
letters so that they want me to dislike
you and create a big problem between us
you better find out who's stealing your
stationery because this profanity is
totally uncalled for and I know you
would never use this kind of stuff
you know what Donald OSAC he wrote back
so you're a class act
oh yeah but I'll get capitulate but
that's what I wrote that was like a but
like a little boy who can't control his
emotions and then feel shame a fence
right yeah really he was also dealing
with a big dog I think Donald to credit
I realized oh I'm dealing with what was
your experiences well I think they had
some clash in Atlantic City because they
both owned hotels and I don't remember
what the details were but they had an
actual issue wouldn't having to do with
real estate in Atlantic City and I guess
they worked it out somehow it might have
been the result I might know what
started it but yeah yeah and so they
opened an improv at Harrah's I think it
was and the opening night was me and
Charles Fleischer and a little bit like
it was a big deal that no translation oh
yeah he's a voice Roger Rabbit he was on
Welcome Back Kotter he was in zodiac he
was the guy that you kind of think was
probably Caribbean loves him he's a pet
and he came to the show with Murph so
trumpet murder in the crowd that's great
and I wish it was a picture oh man
because I was like 1991 1990
it would have been hysterical there's a
picture of me Mervyn chow oh yeah Purvis
was my friend
I never but my friend who is also gay
Merv Griffin was gay and my friend went
to his house to have you know a lunch or
something and Merv had two sprawling
estate with all these young hot men yes
who were like his stack you know which
was great he said young hot men is a
step we're going to love yeah young hot
men just hot as [ __ ] look around the
pool like in shorts like serving drinks
I mean that's what my buddy said he
doesn't he's not going to make him face
a bunch of them pretty not that long
before he died just a four never met him
I'm going to see tapings of the Merv
Griffin when I was a kid when I was like
12 I came and visited California and we
went to see the Merv Griffin Show and
the guests were Jay Leno and dr. Ruth
Westheimer oh my god I remember the
doctor rumor doctor is Brennan so she
was a she was a sex and bring us with a
sex therapist oh I do remember they did
an older lady and she dances
say bye-bye she was always one of you
sir you know she took calls on the Merv
Griffin track then the next guest is
Leno and Leno's like so I don't even say
Nia taking calls but this showed that
it's not live it was calling calling
Merv idea then as I pulled as I walked
out of the parking lot I remember the
other guess was Lucie Arnaz Lucille
Ball's daughter and she almost hit me
with her car but like really almost I
feel bigger
Wow yes I do remember her I didn't look
at USC when I was there and I was one of
the heads of the speakers
you know committee and I was in a
limousine alone with her
and I picked her from the airport and
then she changed her dress in the car
with me in the back of her and then
she's like you're gonna tell your
friends about this one day yeah man Merv
Griffin when I remember just spending
the week with him and I had fantasies of
being his friend like I just like to be
so nice which is funny he was back me up
he's just at five like and I said to him
I said you're this mogul like you're so
like rich and powerful how do you run
your business and he said I show up
everybody sitting at the table and I
just ask for ideas we we just go over
and I basically keep communication open
and that's kind of how we do it I think
there's some times where again I read a
book or I'll hear a story my gang I was
standing my friend
I know our gang else I go like I read
the Senate so I grew up a side line like
that was my Bible man I'd loved it and
so I read about twenty or fifty year
anniversary book is just a history of
Santa at life and they talked about how
back in the day was like you know Jim
Belushi and all the guys they'd get done
and they go to this one bar afterwards
and you know the act it may be it may be
Aerosmith or guns and wrote they would
play just for the small crowd but they'd
all go there yeah and there'd be drugs
and liquor I was like dang I wish I hang
is are part of the yes give yourself a
blow problem because I [ __ ] burn it
but just everyone is so creative you
know in photos how they wrote that show
although if you want some old SNL's from
the 70s you could you can get a good
sell their sketches that make no sense
no what have you done to our life I
always wanted to write for Saturday
Night Live when I lived with Sandler he
left and got a job at Saturday Night
Live and so did Rob Schneider David
Spade yeah and that's all I ever wanted
to do was to write for Saturday Night
Live and I could never get on a job
there and I also was writing sketches
for Jim Carrey for in living color he
would just pay me I was in pocket so
that when he doesn't work he'd have
extra sketches and I kept trying to get
a job that couldn't get those gigs I'm
curious about that because you've
written for a lot of people and people
resuit if you don't read the book did
he's super surprised but comedians that
you've written for you know like
Roseanne Barr and I was like Marnell one
of my first big jobs is writing jokes
I thought her story is the best I
thought her story like her you know it's
not I don't think a lot of people know
but you read her story and just what she
was going through and married it's in
Denver and she was like you know she's
at the Comedy Works and she's making it
and she's dealing with all this stuff
and then she has you know she kind of
sick in the head a little bit too you
know not to quote your book but I know
she has she has some depression issues
and bipolar and just fasting and then
something you give her a show and this
is the thing that no one ever realizes
suddenly you're in charge of a crew of a
hundred people so if you're the type of
person that's not great with people or
yourself or yourself and now you're in
charge of arriving staff and directors
and it's very challenging especially for
comedians who are just suddenly thrown
into this position I always felt like I
had seen that so many times that when
Lena Dunham started girls I knew how to
advise her because I saw Shandling go
through it and Roseanne and so many
people just management just how do I
keep these people happy how do I hire
the right people how do I set the right
vibe because if if you're in a bad mood
you do your whole set if you're the
captain the ship is chaos yeah your
first your education in writing came
from Garry Shandling right yeah and and
all of the more that I even realized at
the time he was the first job I had of
any note was Gary asked me to write
jokes for the Grammys
and that was a huge deal so this was 91
I think and it was here Eric Clapton won
everything for tears in heaven I think
it was 2 years we did a 1 year that Tina
Turner won a ton and Sinatra was on it
and Bono and Nicholson and Bob Dylan
performed her it was right when the Gulf
War started and then Dylan played
masters of war punk style couldn't
understand a word he said and then I
just you know when you're kind of a
mediocre comic and now you're in a room
writing jokes with Chandler and really
all you're doing is writing setups and
he's writing punchlines yeah is that
right yeah cuz he's just such a great
joke artist you go oh you should do
something about how kiss got back
together and and then he would just like
say the joke and you're just lining him
up for him Wow
and I I you know I've learned just by
watching someone do it watching how they
think and you don't even know what
you're learning you're just seeing his
mind working I'm doing a documentary
about Garry Shandling for HBO that's
going to be on March it's gonna be a big
epic thing I keep saying it's like the
OJ doc of Gary really it's just a big
long epic history of Gary issue of
comedy through Gary's eyes how do you
boredom how do you do like how do you
have all these projects we are crashing
we got girls we got love this we got
love they got it we got the big edge out
at the Wilbur
we got judge with a little arrow look
okay rabbit all right now crashing you
got the big sec you got girls you've got
I mean why am I here what are you doing
a fire in the kid and then you got a
Wilbur and you got where it where the
other date either West Rhode Island
shooting a Netflix special in [ __ ]
Montreal it's crazy how do you how do
you keep how do you do the [ __ ] well for
TV you know you're really hiring
showrunners and you're finding
collaborators that know what they're
doing and then you could figure out what
you do so Pete Holmes has his show Pete
Holmes is an amazing writer he's just an
incredible writer he has a vision for
the whole thing I worked hard with him
to get him a great writing staff Greg
Fitzsimmons is over there
I'm really a lot of great people and and
Judah Miller runs it that show with him
and so I break stories with him and I
write episodes I don't spend much time
on set I mainly work on the writing and
the editing and you know so sometimes at
night I just sit with a script but in a
my time with a really clear head saying
okay here's what's left ya do if the set
was chaos then my life would cave in but
you know if you hire great directors and
your scripts are great yeah then a lot
of it is editing and writing and and
that's how we do love as well and and
the Shandling documentary that's you
know it's a year-long project
yeah and it's it's a big piece that's a
that's a big piece of work but I have a
brittle press for you is it more about
things to say no to because I'm sure you
get in how many freakin offers or is
well now I have a light fall and so I'm
trying to see if I can keep it light and
and and read you know sometimes it's
good to just take like four months and
go I'm going to read I'm gonna read all
the books I should have read a long time
ago and and and take another run at
waking my brain up and I think people
don't do that a lot you know right
before a lot of things started turning
in a good direction for me I took a year
off and just read I just said you know I
don't think novels yeah anything in
particular to say does everything I just
sat down away but you know I've never
read The Great Gatsby and I've never you
know guys man any of these books that
everyone says I should have read it even
now I haven't read most of them and so
I'm gonna try to do that in the fall
again because I just I don't know what
it does you touching on a really really
important subject though because I think
it's really important to feed yourself
with when you read even works that have
nothing to do with you or at about
people that live a very different life
than you do or just the great classics
there's a reason that those stories are
still relevant or they're quote unquote
classics because they are they have
something in them that feeds you I think
that kind of like either humbles you
makes you sit back and kind of realize
that you're part of something much
bigger or not part of
much bigger which also has its own value
it also kind of maybe amplifies your own
limitations
it also Tunes you into how people think
know what a great writer is describing
the inner life of somebody it reminds
you of how you should create your
characters and how deeply you should
create them because when things are bad
usually they're shallow and if you take
the time the way Gary did and said okay
we're going to figure out Hank Kingsley
who is this guy to the bone
this isn't here's my acting teacher by
the way Oh amazing it for five years
yeah so so Jeffrey Campbell
oh yeah the great yeah uh and he was so
amazing in that and you know Jeffrey
tells a story about he's got a book out
yep a great book about his life yeah
Jeffrey does yeah just put it out oh wow
I got to get it because Jeffrey talked
about when he really wanted that part
and his acting teacher Milton Katselas
said call him he said because it was
between it was between you know Jeffrey
and somebody else you and Jeffrey called
Gary and Jeffrey was like stumbling and
I just think I could really do this part
and I just think I did really good for
it and you know I would never ever do
this I would never ever call somebody
I've never done this before I would
never do this and you know what Gary
said Gary goes Hank Kingsley would well
and he went and he hung up the phone he
said I got it yeah yes great story great
I was always such a fan of Jeffrey oh
and I remember that moment
oscar's Gary played me the auditions and
I said wait a second that's the guy
who's my favorite character on NYPD Blue
plays a judge and he also is a judge in
injustice at saw IRA him throwing the
plates and he happened to be someone
that was just very on my radar as my
favorite character actor and when he
showed me I was like that's the best guy
of all dude and justice for all so I
took his acting class because I found
out that that guy who threw plates in
and justice for all I'm serious really
he was getting well and justice for all
if anybody hasn't seen it Al Pacino it
still holds up it's one of the great
movies am I wrong Coates it's one of the
great and it's one of the great it's
what made Al Pacino
in a lot of ways besides the Godfather I
mean where that was the first yelling
Pacino holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] it's about a
lawyer and it's it's one of the most
beautiful movies ever but Jeffrey Tambor
who comes in with that he goes crazy he
has he has a toupee and it anyway the
point is I took that class and that's
kind of why and-and-and does he does he
still teach yeah I don't like this
Jeffery was a Scientologist and he left
the church he quote-unquote blue yeah
and when he blue he just stopped
teaching at the Beverly at the Beverly
Hills Playhouse why I didn't you know
classes from not a Scientologist but I
took classes there ten years everybody
Jim Carrey does it took the young Milton
and Jeffrey yes I was like a very high
being I be in class and literally I mean
it'd be like Giovanni Ribisi and I would
be doing it seeing Burt Reynolds would
be over there I guess I'm it was crazy I
heard Jim Carrey recently you know he
doesn't do a lot of interviews a lot of
press he has that show on Showtime right
now I'm dying up here which I love yes
love it I saw the versal it's great it's
great but he did interview on Howard
Stern so my day and do you know Jim K to
me man that's that's it yeah and he was
talking about on there just his whole
process to at The Comedy Store how we
quit doing impressions and just his
whole process and he was saying to your
point you know you take whatever a year
off you read you like sushi where's that
now what's two years off it takes two
years off once there's get out of things
kind of focus on read and straddle and
then jump back into it she says I got a
reset now I guess it's really important
I think that's right that's why
traveling all that stuff is important
but it's uh kind of groove yeah and it's
hard I mean the people that we like like
say like Neil Young they just reinvent
themselves they've come at things from
new angles and so you could repeat
yourself your whole whole life but in
order to switch gears you do need to
have some perspective and to stop and go
you know what am i doing and am i stuck
in a box with what I'm doing like I
wouldn't define me and like I just saw
Paul Feig sign to do this thriller with
a Blake Lively I thought yeah that's
that's what you have to do at some point
to shake it out yeah now we have
interesting moment though with Jeffrey
and acting class and there's a whole ear
of
that yeah those classes it was very
influential but they I don't really know
that much about that that connection
between Scientology and acting I don't
think there is one III was that no I
don't III so I spent 10 years there and
I and I and I you know having done I was
around Scientologists wanted Kirstie
Alley I did her shown so yeah we shot at
the science or Heather yeah and so for
me I was just way too developed and I
wasn't too old to even get kind of be
sucked into that I mean I just you know
but um and I don't begrudge it I saw a
lot of I knew a lot of quote-unquote
Scientologists if you want to call that
who are great people and well-adjusted
very talented and stuff some of whom was
grown up in the church but III think
that that was a factor of the active
active recruitment by the church before
they were sort of exposed by the
internet but it was sort of like you
know where where celebrity was
considered by ron l ron hubbard to be
something to be coveted something to be
sort of get gotten close to and
celebrities and actors were held and
high regard by him this is what i really
like a god what they said it was they
said Scientology was great yeah your Tom
Cruise yes everyone else has been a yeah
and were there a lot of stories like
that but my experience with it was never
negative I didn't wasn't going to be
involved in it and I knew that were
Scientologists from Jenna Elfman to you
know Jen Aspen my friend er they were
all talented really great people they
just happen to have been into this
philosophy as young people that worked
for them yeah right I mean I did a I did
a benefit for 9/11 and the Scientology
Center yeah i NC dit and got up and
started telling basically kind of dirty
jokes pretending to be an Israeli porn
star as I think is a line I make up to
my bed I make nice like that it was
springtime for Hitler they were all like
it got really quiet and a bunch of them
came home goes it's a church you can't
do that they were really nice about it
and so I I went out and I apologized I
was like sorry and you know it killed as
I said it was a whole church full of
Scientologists and I went I got to tell
you when I said yes to doing this
um thing all my friend said at the
Scientology Center I said yeah and they
all said be careful and everybody kind
of laughed and I said I know they might
tie me to a chair and make me take
responsibility for myself are you and
all you know anyway I could do no wrong
after that but it was it was I had a lot
of interesting experiment but I don't
think that it lends itself the prolonged
point I don't think that Scientology
made better actors out of peace yeah
that's because I'm a self-help freak you
know I'm really like so I just like I'm
always reading something like animation
is it old Wayne died ready ready oh this
is my favorite like relationship guy
John well we would try to well would
journey that happens how reading books
like this that's amazing and I actually
get helps for writing because it's all
about psychology and motivations and why
people do things but I certainly hoard
self-help advice and then I think it
becomes a soup in my head and I drown in
it and I can't get anything done really
but you're you know because you're so
highly affected like you're you're a
successful as it gets in show business
right see fell one more time can we
track every times Brian success it's
just awkward for me no but it's just a
Natalie you just all chained open it's
judge your add about myself
our listeners are doing great we're
gonna get roasted for know I can't be
happier the reason I keep reiterating
that is because like I always when I
look at you I think of there's like this
sort of end game right so in a way
you're at the finish line I mean I'm
just saying if you we look at it yeah
I've been in a business for twenty
[ __ ] three years I know the
difference I mean I can see it so I'm up
there with Merv yeah correct you're your
mogul but then what cracks me up is your
reading you know why we're all in
ventilating I learn there we're all
mentally hanging by a thread yeah I
don't know did you sexually come in like
made it what's up [ __ ] well here's a
bars of gold know who needs cash just
think the discussion lies in that space
where it's like okay made it right on
paper yet you feel like you're there's
so much work to be done that's why you
crack me up when I see you with your
notebook after doing a set and you're
literally you're you're walking you look
like a you look like one of those nerds
from school with your books like a lot
of course you want
I want to put you in a ball and go I'm
not saying this to make this awkward
I expect that out of you like when I saw
you at the comic store you're writing i
I've been sad if you weren't doing that
like when I see Joe Rogan he's recording
every set I expected out of those guys
my fee bill Bergland you better be
[ __ ] 2 hours 3 hours a day riding I
expect that out of you guys if I if you
came in here he's a slob you're 30
minutes late it would have broke my
heart man it'll broke man I remember
when Louie was getting ready for this
big tutorial last year and there's a
whole budget night he came in to the
Comedy Store and they would announce
that last second it would sell out
immediately and I opened up for him on
one of those shows and I and I just
thought this guy's working so hard on
this he cares so much he having so many
shows to get ready for this tour and
then you see what it turns into
it's like Kevin Harvick Kevin Hart
United's a new specials he's getting
ready to come out and he's been in the
valley and he'll announce it that day he
does four or five shows the small room
back back to back and to me like
especially this day and age it's tough
to find inspiration it's tough to find
role models you know because a lot of
people don't talk about that so you got
the way you inspires by seeing these
guys do it so when I see you know Kevin
Hart who's doing six shows in a night
getting ready for a special you want to
talk about something he's made it if
that's what you expect out of him you
know to me that's so cool to see six
shows of the night nuts but are they
that's what I don't like that yeah nuts
yeah but are they re they reading
self-help I love the more Kevin Hart
wrote a self-help book he has a new book
and I radically yes I self out bunions
yeah it's advice from Kevin and he is a
DC he was like that I mean I did a pilot
with him in the year 2000 I as soon as
he moved to LA his manager Dave Becky
said oh you got a no Kevin locked and he
was a kid we did a pilot together it was
him as you know young wannabe actor
comedian and Jason Segel as a young
wannabe acting new holers young wannabe
actress living in the valley who's
called North Hollywood and January Jones
was in it
was anything it is ABC and then remember
when Amy got that it didn't get picked
up and
and and and the joke of the whole
episode shows it was a young Kevin Hart
who kept talking about how giant he was
going to be and he kept that was his
joke he's like he's like I'm gonna be
like Chris Tucker
except you can't understand him he
talked too fast with me he's gonna say
me somebody being Chris Tigers gonna say
me you can't insane him and and then it
didn't go and so we put him on
undeclared he did a bunch of episodes of
undeclared and he was in the 40 old
virgin that was what that's where and I
yeah I always thought this guy's the
funniest but I couldn't crack like I
just couldn't get the show picked up or
I couldn't get the project going and so
it's amazing to see how hard that guy
worked to make it a successful tour of
all time still and he is and a great guy
and everybody loves him in the room he
comes in and makes the room better do
you do you know could you know something
special about him shut up because I'm
sure you see I wasn't sure I can't say I
thought this guy was gonna be the
biggest community in the world what I
thought was this kind makes me laugh my
ass and he should he should be a star
reason only are you always funny but
even then he was like friends with jay-z
and he had a sense that he had to be
good at business yes and as a young kid
he's talking about his clothes and he
would take out his clothes me and very
thoughtfully but of his clothes and he
would take out like a shirt and a pair
of pants and he would call it his set
he's like you like that set like that
that clothes alone we would laugh about
it because he was acting like a
superstar as a basically unemployed
young heir so yeah but he especially
like you know like this book was the
power of intention by Wayne Dyer the
whole book is about setting goals and
how you creates a certain mental
environment to make them happen that's
all Kevin Hart did fairly on instincts
there's a technique of organizing your
mind right I mean yes they do believe in
yourself and you still feel like you
still have to do that my god is what I I
just like asking these questions because
I oh I'm always fascinated with the fact
that success is a verb it's not a noun
well my critical voice wants me to stop
it wants you to stop oh I've got that
voice in my head that's just shut the
[ __ ] up really no one cares and I'm
always at war we
a part of my brain that is very low
self-esteem it's not all of my brains is
one part of it what don't you think most
comics have that my I do I think it
drives all of us I think we're we're
constantly trying to prove that we
deserve to be up there that our work is
valuable and maybe you couldn't do the
work if you didn't have it but my aunt
does not go away and as you get into
each stage of life it it turns into
something slightly different but it's
coming at you I said that the other day
I said you know you're always told you
have to love yourself and it's really
important to believe in yourself and I
disagree I think that what drives me is
always this sense of inadequacy and sort
of like I have a hole I can't fill and I
don't mind like I've never liked myself
that much though I look in the mirror
all the time always looking for
something to change so that's something
to kind of improve I still believe I'm
going to be if I keep if I really apply
myself and do more incline bench I'm
gonna be 50 where as you are we never
total incline yeah but kind of my garage
will work out I'm spotting I'll spot you
I'm gonna get that dad body hit the dead
buck yeah but yeah dude you have to
believe in yourself and then but your
self-hatred is what makes you funny yeah
well your characters you always start
with these like very sort of sensitive
characters like a lot of the characters
in your movies are not guys that are
benching 400 pounds or can beat the [ __ ]
out everybody in the bar they're in fact
the exact opposite they're these
vulnerable people say nerds yes like
people say in it it's due to your credit
especially to stay in Hollywood they say
nerds run Hollywood I even think I saw
Wonder Woman the other day I even think
they made a point of making her a nerd
that was part of it that she's no
all-powerful but also weird with the guy
she likes and she's on she doesn't fit
in and identity and I think that you
know the truth is I think everyone feels
that way some people can overcome it to
a certain extent you know that's why
it's always like funny when I forgot who
I was talking about this with but you
know when you're like with people who
are amazing like LeBron James and and
they've mastered a way to get in flow in
in their athletics just to get in the
zone
they're not doubting themselves yeah we
were talking about Federer the other day
you know this guy just doesn't make an
unforced error 34 hours and if you've
ever played tennis how hard that is
yeah and and I think for comedy you can
get in that space where you forget and
you hit some gear where you're not
doubting yourself and you're just
connecting to some creative pipe in the
universe and that's where you want to
get but man it is it's a tough place to
go if you have damage yeah you know if
you have like normal childhood psychic
damage yeah to like yourself enough to
let go of your insecurities to let your
brain do it has to do maybe that's good
I don't know I don't think I know really
too many comics that are that happy with
themselves and just uber confident yeah
I don't think you like really cocky it's
like in a word oh it's so weird to be
first bird I just did a panel with Bill
burr yeah for Netflix was all these like
you know comedy show runners bird it's
in front like 200 people couldn't kill
harder oh and the executive ends he's
just like how does people hate me and
I'm up there going I'm so unfunny look
how funny Berle yeah and he's walking up
going again I wasn't good yeah I marry
did we did the ice house and he was like
oh my god I guess just this time of my
starting new stuff it's always so dicey
like the bill you just [ __ ] destroy
like it like there's nothing left they
had to bring a meal and stuff above you
and bring him out on stretchers from
laughter and talk we measure his energy
on stage so I did a Largo with him a few
months back he's just has the most focus
intense energy is not half as intent
he's never lost his outrageous zoo old
girl always has outrage generally at the
world he's like it is angry intense and
about it's an outright I've never
laughed so hard at a comedian we're on
the same bill at the Comedy Store I get
done like I gotta see Birdman so I win
the crown stood in the back
I was laughing so hard I peers come in
laughing it's really it's remarkable
because it's also just a discipline to
get in a headspace to care that much
yeah because you can walk through it's
okay to make money and you're you know a
celebrity and you're flying first
or whatever it is you know he's got he's
doing very well he's like our Beyonce he
can you watch me I'll bust and he'll be
on one wasted movement like you watch I
saw in concert I could memorize there's
so much choreography and and she's
singing that I thought how can you
remember more than 4 songs worth of
choreography this thousands of moves
here yeah uh she here went in her mouth
for a minute into a school and she like
made it into like part of the dance yes
and it's so focused and confident and
yet that's that's what I was thinking or
is like to her flat ass because I don't
that's a stretch yeah I'd have to
evidence well I was but I don't think of
Beyonce but I get Wiese and sorted like
her ass but the good bad dog fell cubits
or black members of pop you know what I
meant he's our like our Kendra now her
yeah yeah yeah yes who I couldn't leave
house short he how small he was Kendrick
we were doing that spike thing only
Italian otherwise did you do a thing
with him now we were in the psych Awards
in you came out and anyway I told Brian
wit that's the greatest hip-hop artists
on all eight numbers that little guy
went Wichita bronze six eight like what
guys got to be a big guy really about
rap just a super rappers would huge guys
in your head ol rappers or 17:70 talk
let it gasps hey and they're just like I
think they're just like comics in the
sense that they're poets they try to
express themselves they're nerds I mean
you know you you bet that probably fit
into how you become that person to
express yourself that way at some point
yeah you know at some point Kendrick
Lamar was a you know avoiding a beating
and his talent give to find him so you
like oh I'm not gonna be up that guy
like that guy Dre Dre was in his
basement
he wasn't out hanging out cube was the
same way they would like they were
literally in their basement creating
they were not out banging no people you
don't see the people don't don't say
banging but people don't see straight
don't ever say baby I saw her in your
size your old life again it's a gang
there's a bang in the matter
her Street you say back nobody because
people you know Kendrick Lamar and the
ice cube and the game like those guys
are artists man they just come from that
rough life but you don't look at them
like you know it's a Wiccan comparison
give me where than Beyonce and Bill burr
but you know ket like Kendrick Lamar is
you know the same artists or small guys
like a Seth Rogen because you just Seth
Rogen comes from this nerdy what are you
Canadian yeah you know and then tentacle
Mars that nerdy black kid they don't
make that into Park I thinking from
somewhat of a mellow alien went to buck
went to Junior High School for the Arts
no I think it was in Baltimore Sonya but
he went with you I'm almost positive
what - Julia you go actually are but are
you saying that my pillow get up that
rap music is completely off your radar
me you know not completely I'm you
listen to it I do I mean uh you can't in
my kids do so there's a lot in my world
for the last whatever fourteen years I I
remember listening to the dr. Dre record
the chronic was probably the first
record that we really listened to yeah I
don't find it that relaxing to this have
playing cuz Mike now my ear goes to the
lyric so if you're sitting around the
house I don't like it's like having
someone talking in my ear yeah I like it
in the car with the kids and I also like
how much they like it
yeah you know but then sometimes it's so
dirty like come on haha yeah I'll be
like in the car my daughter's and it's
like it's just filthy as a human can
speak and I'm trying to be like cool dad
like this is a nice number
yeah you don't want to shut it off it'll
be good yeah I'm really enjoying this
word not the vagina but it's really hot
and the kids don't seem to care it's
funny I don't think they hear the lyrics
I don't see that they're shocked by
anything as I remember like when I like
knew about certain phrases or certain
sexual things as a kid and they find out
everything so early but don't seem
thrown by it yeah it's just noticing
like when you think of this whole
politically correct mania this I think
it's pretty out of control I felt bad
for for Kathy Griffin I think it was a
mistake
yeah Forte's uh yeah I think it's pretty
sighs I think it's it's an error in
judgment but not important
yeah I think you're not you be not she's
amazing she's great and she's hysterical
and a nice person and I think as a
result of her frustration she did
something that she shouldn't have done
but I think it's it's nothing that
anyone should care about five minutes
after yeah it's just it's just you know
we've ever done photo shoots as you guys
have right people always hand in your
props you know like what we did knocked
up every little one set to dress up like
a baby you know he shows up in
photographers video it was trying to get
a bit of diaper put him in a giant crib
and that is what happens and so if
you're doing the photo shoot and
someone's like hey when you hold this
bloody head if you are tired or you're
trying to get out of there in a mood or
whatever you're you just saw something
on the news that bugged you there might
be a moment we like that sounds funny
yeah and you had a moment and you and
you miss it and I think that's what
we're supposed to do is we don't you
think after like so she and I agree with
you maybe like hey do this as I check it
out whoa ha ha ha but you know she's
just okay those photos like she knew
like the magnitude they could happen for
sure yeah and I think that burn Hamlet
is yeah I saw her apology you know and
she put her first apology oh yeah that's
right yeah for sure where that joke
comedians are supposed to make bad jokes
we're supposed to find the line of taste
and event and the only way we know what
we're doing is that we cross it here's
my line and that's what we're here for
and when someone makes a mistake
no comedic error in judgment should
affect your career I think she didn't
bounce that can be fine oh I think that
her crowd loves her it will in a year it
will eliminate her more rocket-like she
wants to see an end job but she wouldn't
people don't realize like she lost the
scene ends up she worked one night New
Year's she's not part undeniably the
best thing in a way I mean you're right
I think it's going to just you know
because her crowds gonna sit on here
what's going to happen it's going to go
down and then any publicity is good
publicity lence can roll back in her
favor I think but I think as a result of
everyone's tension about Trump because
even the people who like Trump quietly
are going like
is he crazy like like is this the same
guy making choices is he smart does he
understand what happens when you engage
you know fighter jets over Syria even
his own staff I think are always up they
don't know what he's gonna do is he
listening to the last guy he spoke to
see I think everyone's on eggshells but
the same time even though the comic she
would know this in the side we live in
with Isis and the way they traumatized
everyone the way they scary one is by
these beheadings and he do that maybe
you [ __ ] hate Trump I don't care what
your take is on it but the headless very
riad it's very real because that's a
legit problem you have today oh sure and
I think that that's you know and I think
she understands that so then the
questions become something different
which is do we forgive comedians for
making mistakes and I think in a very
stressful environment where everyone is
stressed whether you're Republican or
Democrat you're stressed just by the
fact that everyone's disagreeing
comedians are trying to figure out how
to comment about us and our making
mistakes here and there and I think that
they should be forgiving because we
don't forgive regular people and one of
the things that I'm noticing is that the
work environment and and the media is
very unforgiving and I think when people
lose abilities well like so they're so
in over one of the board members not to
see you as a board member
turn to Arianna Huffington because they
were talking about getting more women on
the board yeah and he turned to Arianna
Huffington and said well one thing's for
sure it'll be a lot more talkative
around here something to that extent and
he had to resign because it's a revenge
yeah the speech police were all over him
and to me that's a funny comment and if
you're that insecure about your movement
or whatever's happening and you see this
in academia I mean you know you've got
you've got certain professors that are
like this one Rogan had a professor on
who is a biology professor and I guess
he refused to stay home they wanted to
have sort of all white people would stay
home that day and only people of color
could come to the custom to some
demonstration or to to to college in
sort of commemoration he was like I'm
not doing that I'm a teacher I'm wiping
I'm
I don't identify that way and so he was
being called a racist and all that and I
think that I think that academia has
just lost its mind I think that I hear a
lot about it you know just hearing about
it from kids who are college age now
yeah and it's you know it's it's funny
because I remember Joan Rivers was
always a no apology person yeah and she
said the worst things ever but her
theory was I will never do anything and
she survived and thrived as a result I'm
like no way - I feel like that is the
way to go I really do
I feel like people even if you're wrong
if you stand by it at least draw a line
in the sand be like well least least we
know where you can tell the truth -
right I mean isn't the truth like so as
a writer and somebody who's kind of like
coming up with these stories do you find
you have to check yourself because
there's so much of this is about the
truth well I don't know where right now
yeah that people are paying attention to
how I frame these things I I'm you know
I think Colin Quinton said the best
thing he said you there's no problem
with any of this just mean what you say
yeah it's a lot of it is when you're
thoughtless you get in trouble when you
can't back up your opinions but yeah
there's a lot of crazy political
correctness someone from Saturday Night
Live made a joke about Trump's son and
and got fired and I feel like there you
know if you got a lifetime of comedy and
good-hearted work and you just you'd
make a verbal mistake I think you should
have the opportunity to discuss it but
no one's careers that's what I look at
bill bill Marv right right he said he
owes oh no I'm not a house ninja right
you used the n-word which that that's a
tough Ellen a white guy but you can see
so there's a lot of intersections
there's a context but in the context he
was doing it when you watch it and I'm
not advocating this at all it's not okay
that he did that when you watching like
he shouldn't lose his job over time and
that's what I feel like there's there's
a group of people that aren't interested
in persuasion or changing the world are
changing anybody's mind what what I feel
like a lot of the speeds police and a
lot of the politically correct the sort
of social justice words are more
interested in is punishment yeah
and power and so when though and they'll
come out to your job I mean oh like
you're talking about your career and
your reputation to things that take a
lifetime to build some still form of
bullying in it it's not only that it's
also a form of destruction and murder
because it's almost like they're almost
like I always feel like they're poachers
but at least poachers take something's
in the body these people come along they
go oh you said one bad thing we're going
to brand you a homophobe a sexist and a
racist of fun we're going to also we
demand that you resigned so that you
don't have a job anymore we're going to
ruin your reputation let's move on to
the next guy we didn't change him of his
mind what we did is punish that guy I
don't know we're going to make the world
a better place by censoring an old white
CEO for example Roger Ailes who might've
been an [ __ ] I don't know but the
point is that I don't think that that is
the best way to if provided you try to
make the world a better place and change
minds I don't know that that kind of
censorship that kind of coordinated
attack remember Alec Baldwin called that
photographer a [ __ ] and they were
calling him a homophobe Alec Baldwin's a
great word he's also yeah don't take
that word away from me [ __ ] keeping
Cosco stock deep in the condo Maya okay
I'll use that my whole life I get mad
when they how dare you try to take that
work implies that we think that that's
not a positive thing to do yeah where
are you better act especially we got a
wig on as we finish up I'm gonna call my
uber then I'm gonna walk out of here
directly she god takes me directly to
things over chopper yeah and I got rid
of my car and then I just why'd you
really not a place it just I I had this
Lexus Hybrid from the 90s I got it hey
meadow 2008 and I could tell it was done
it's done but I didn't replace it get a
[ __ ] chauffeur you're you're way too
rich to not only get a chauffeur don't
be that get a family or as I call them
that have been so for hire like
celebrities to drive you around
periodically out of worry like Bruce
came on in or you're not a car guy see
just I'm not a car guy I like I like a
good car but I'm not like get my muscle
he's literally calling an uber as we
speak I have to
I don't know where I'm going though so
this is I don't have all the information
and I'd even know exactly where I am
you're down in a down near the beach you
know I there I am I'm going to run yeah
we can Cal just closed the shop closed
the show my bloody dates and then plug
your guys analysis saying I have a real
appointment after there's like one of
those medical things you can't you can't
miss oh yeah this is not like a lateness
what's your medical thing nothing bad
okay just getting a couple limbs removed
there you go study your brain this was
fun thanks for doing this father I
enjoyed every I'm sure you coming out
man really really appreciate it yeah
soon be at the Wilbert running your
special I mean let me actually tell you
the exact date that's all here at all I
feel like I've been bad plugging because
I don't know when anything is you know
like self-promotion of cars I just saw
clothing it's all just disorganized but
okay ready this will this is the actual
information tap Italica Gator we're okay
the Wilbur which is Monday July 24th two
shows second shows for charity and then
the day before that the 23rd I'm at in
Ridgefield Connecticut at the Ridgefield
Playhouse and then I am in Providence
Rhode Island on the 25th at the Columbus
theatre and then I'm in Montreal there's
still some tickets left like thank you
and watch at all laughs yeah and the big
set go see the big sec if you want to
see a good movie if you like that Jesus
everywhere that'll be a New York in LA
the next two weeks and then everywhere
July 14 boom well thank you for coming
on and we have you got Apatow pleasure
Congrats on your success Chad my Merv
like success Judd Apatow one of my faves
mance what a good time smart dude yeah
man I want I want audience to chalk up
how many times you said successful I but
he what fascinates me is that he's
successful but so down-to-earth and so
hungry and I just get a kick out of
somebody who because the reason I say
that is because I've been trying to
write for a long time in earnest like
I've been trying I mean maybe I'm not a
writer at the end of
honestly but even is this because it's
not just that it's like I have so many
friends being here in 23 years so you
have to take this in my history in
account and I start I came here in 1995
if I told you how many people I know who
went to theater school film school and
who spent a lifetime trying to write
just one movie how many writers I know
who spent a lifetime trying to get one
movie made like I mean so many people
right I mean so many and I think I know
maybe three people that have done it and
they've got it in moderately
successfully and then you see a guy that
who's been doing it over and over again
movies him in my view are so good like
every movie like I Love You Man super
bad every movie touchless Moe is [ __ ]
- mainly dude I don't know but so
prolific that it's actually mind-blowing
to me that he's that good at what he
does like it's mind-blowing like I'm not
impressed with comedians so comedians
like we talked about all his communities
I love
they're all great yeah but it's not a
mystery to me I guess with Judd what he
does is a mystery like it's a mystery
that he's that good at what he does
because writing a movie no idea with all
that I'm saying we don't have to keep
your mind me so for me it wasn't about
reminding him out successfully was he
knows how it was what I was trying to
get out was just the fact that the guy
is like what is his process like how is
it that he does this and also it's
obvious part of it's just the fact that
he has that feeling of talent not hating
I think a lot of people can't chalk it
up like love you just don't have the
brain that jet apps out there you're
just not a fart it's same with sports
same with actors comedians you just
don't have the time just don't have a
talent the mentoring play we're born
with it yeah we're not all created equal
it all starts the same certain line
correct no matter how many books you
read in your neighbor yes you would
never be the right of Judd Apatow is
your friends will never be Judd Apatow I
will never be Judd Apatow and neither
will I there's no mystery that which is
why I'm what I want to take this this
moment to say that I'm quitting the bit
to the jet half top Wow you get dude I
just want to see that movie any movie
does any movie this well I've been like
you're asking like I like Pete holes I
can really relate to Pete Holmes he's
little too beta for me right
like he's on the show I was like ah like
I wouldn't hang out with Pete at a bar
but I like B I like his opinion I think
he's funny also special he's very funny
so I can relate to that but I like I'm
not crate you know it's just not like
type of dude he's like in my circle now
I watch crashing he's hilarious
yeah [ __ ] he'd love to eat something
matching by the way I know does the the
Raney's would come the store owners yeah
hilarious yep it's [ __ ] great right
now but yeah man shut up yeah Judd
Apatow that's a now I feel like now that
we got Judd I feel like we should be
getting our scores never Franks I mean
Sylvester Stallone who is the guy you
want to get on I want to get I want to
get Kevin Hart on but I don't know man
we should keep on keeping on there's no
I really want yeah it's funny shows it
shows it shows you a good kid laugh yeah
yeah
and he's good but I don't yeah yeah that
would make somebody's real quick since
judge mentioned superwoman yeah
Arnel super wonder Wonder Woman yeah
since we're just we didn't do in Kern
Yvette's just one she's making 300
thousand per movie there's like three
movies she signed on for three hundred
thousand who uh gah-gah god oh yeah well
they lock you in we can get I talked to
Patty about getting gaalan and her and
Patty on the podcast suite so I think we
can do that that'll be the last units
like the same with the Lord of the Rings
characters remember what I thought he
was saying how like he signed on for
those whatever four or five they made
you think they're balling Zegna
they know this thing's would be big yes
we get you from this but I got news for
you I got news for you in Hollywood when
your movie makes that much money hmm you
can renegotiate yes a lot of analysis
she's Wonder Woman so me tough to make a
second be a successful without her I'll
watch she's like I'm not doing that
watch it watch this all you got to do is
this I'm telling you got my neck I got I
don't know how I'm gonna shoot on when
are we shooting I got this I don't know
I got hurt last time and I just feel
like I don't know it's not worth it
anymore
high five I have stories and people
especially the way she looks and she'd
go on to do whatever the [ __ ] I'll be
reading eager to get her money
yes she did back at her agency won't
even comes out her agents are going to
go hey listen
obviously let's uh let's step up a
student right yeah you're not a courtesy
unless you want a better Wonder Woman
yeah she's adequate knocking no your
that's that's your one that's Wonder
Woman for the sequel so hey hey guys can
we share become wetter beak a little bit
let's figure it out so much how well
it's done they're not gonna eat I mean
are you surprised that she made three
hundred thousand for each film I thought
that was given for her tonight you know
what I am that's pretty low oh it's very
low that's crazy though but she's
unknown actress aforesaid not the
fastest years movies i'ma say it again
she's unknown actor ya know like for her
this is her big break grow the the film
should get after this by what she's
thinking through another granite Lima
star of Wonder Woman this huge budget
yeah you're gonna do whatever it takes
yeah I mean Patti didn't get locked as
we will do it for free for the second
one so she's going to be able to
renegotiate make some money but they
always do that if they're smart you know
this incident they like it and then you
know you know it is like the USC it's
like you're not the UFC you're a part of
this thing you know that the movie is
the star so depending but when you get
when you have an opening the fluid yeah
not really because well there's like one
on our rules right like the mob crew is
well well Tom Cruise different if your
own Iron Man yeah yeah so we'll do
that's again again if you separate cell
phone actor like I can't see anybody
being better than Robert Downey jr. as
Iron Man now you're getting 15 million
dollars right I mean that's the way it
is so I was in the car when somebody was
negotiating Robert Downey jr. 's money
for a movie and it was pretty
mind-blowing egos when when they were
talking about the kind of numbers thrown
around I was like um usually did but you
know what he's worth it yeah I go to I
would go to a movie for him that that's
worth yeah I'm Robert Downey jr. fan and
yeah our know it's been a fun episode we
got if Judd Apatow my brother I do man
Comedy Central Coast central yes the
random job goes from being a UFC
heavyweight to now shooting something on
Comedy Central this ain't happening
no no man
let me show you have you reflected on
that no not yet not today I won't I'm
not getting done
I'm sure tonight when I link that home
to my undies I will yeah or tomorrow but
right now I don't wanna think about
making a bigger deal when it is you go
and chin I didn't get it
I already got an invite the way I get it
if I'm not doing it I got it no no but
like to date for my fans they did hey
sign up here yet sleet take it right but
then they send you like you see yeah I
guess they pick you they pick whoever
out of the people that applied for it I
would have the information early but
whoever applied for it they'll just
email you back if you got the tickets
it's a some of my manager attacks and
ouch and have them hit them up so you
make sure you tickets I don't know it's
going on if not we still have you know
stuff to do here so why wouldn't you
make it in time yeah if we did more
shows would I hear you min well boom and
I'll have some more like you said I have
more dates coming up soon they just fit
gave me some of the dates I know just
gonna stop my head
Salt Lake Chicago Detroit and Denver big
round right now that's all I can think
of right I'm going to be at I'll be at
the comedy zone in Charlotte North
Carolina get your tickets now at tea fat
cake calm or comedy zone in Charlotte
North Carolina July 20 21 22 and the
only tickets you can get right now that
are available from the iron Phoenix they
end up live and that is July 20th
Phoenix get Joe take it the ground
Brissac down present it be that's it
buddy
this is the fire kid with Judd Apatow
we're out